joining me today is a biologist a former
professor at Evergreen State who is now
a professor in exile brett weinstein
welcome back to the rubin report thanks
for having me back on professor in exile
my friend that's what it says on your
Twitter bio which means it's your most
defining characteristic right now that
has become the tenor of my life all
right so I went into the Reuben report
archives they're very much like the Jedi
archives I went into the Reuben record
archives
this morning the you were on this show
originally on may 30th 2017 so that's
about a year and a half ago it was just
as the Evergreen brouhaha was beginning
you you still were employed at the time
which probably seems like a lifetime ago
so I think first maybe we should just
play a little catch-up from then now
just to be clear you you have been on
the show one since then you were on with
your brother Eric and we did a little
bit about Evergreen in your life but I
saw I thought first let's just do catch
up on on what happened where you're at
where you're going and then we're gonna
do sort of new territory and we're gonna
cover a lot of biology and all that
great so May 30th of 2017 would be
exactly one week into the riots the
protest at my classroom that became
relatively famous happened on May 23rd
so one weekend I was sitting in this
chair and that feels like a lifetime ago
does it I mean it was like it for me and
I think less has happened to me although
it's been pretty busy here and have the
transformation of my life and Heather's
life in that period has been so dramatic
that it's hard to even relate you know
I've never had so much happen in a year
yeah so okay so for people that don't
know anything about the story and I
suspect there's very few watching this
at the moment can you give me like the
92nd recap of what happened so can that
be done in 90 seconds let's say it can
be done with with carnage yeah say I
feared this question more than any other
because there's so much detail in the
story it can't be covered properly
alright give a give a Cliff Notes
version that basically
and an explainer equity and inclusion
movement got started on my campus as it
is on virtually every campus and the new
president of Evergreen through fuel on
the fire
he used the division over that issue to
accomplish things he could not have
accomplished otherwise I tried to block
his moves to dismantle the excellent
part of evergreens teaching model which
Heather and I were using to full effect
and I became effectively enemy number
one of this equity and inclusion
movement they arranged a protest at my
classroom very dramatic fifty students
showed up demanding my resignation not a
single one of them was a student I had
ever encountered but in any case they've
made a terrible error they filmed their
confrontation with me they uploaded it I
now know to Facebook somebody else in
the public picked those videos up and
broadcast them and the world watched me
tried to reason with them and that set
things in motion we're Evergreen started
using me as an excuse for its problems
it blamed me for what happened there for
the drop-off and enrollment for all
sorts of things and I started engaging
with the public about what was taking
place at Evergreen about issues of
freedom of expression free inquiry on
college campuses and increasingly
evolutionary biology which you know
people did not initially really
understand that that was the focus that
I had not freedom of speech issues yeah
now increasingly that's what people want
to talk to me about right although we're
gonna get to plenty of that because I
know that's what your your real focus
and passion is and it's sort of funny
that now you've been thrust into this
but in effect you were protesting
putting racist policies on campus is
that fair to say yes and this is one of
the I think hardest lessons for people
to learn
good people get the idea that you can
spot the right side by certain
heuristics and you know there's been a
historical fact of oppressed people
tending to be people of color etc and so
people have gotten lazy about
recognizing who's in the right
if you follow a principle to its logical
conclusions in other words if you're
against segregation for example as I am
then when the segregationists are
telling white people to leave campus who
are asking them to leave campus then you
are committed to standing against
segregation and when you do stand
against segregation the world goes crazy
because people who are being lazy about
recognizing which side is defending the
principle that they they subscribe to
they fall out in the wrong place and so
anyway yes it is your principles and
adherence to them that gets you in
trouble yeah okay so you then show up in
this studio a week after this whole
thing goes down it was your first public
interview about any of this what did you
think at the time was going to happen by
talking about this publicly or what was
your hope at least by talking about this
publicly well you know initially my hope
was to expose the foolishness at
Evergreen and save the college from its
own worst instincts because your
audience may not care terribly deeply
about this but for a small number of
people for four thousand students at a
time Evergreen was actually a wonderful
experiment in which it was possible for
people who haven't had tremendous
educational advantages before they got
to college to have an experience that
couldn't be reproduced anywhere else
evergreens model was so unique that if
you ended up in the right classrooms
with professors who really cared it was
it was like no other place and and you
were given incredible freedom as a
professor to do what you wanted with
these kids right I believe that the
position
Heather and I had was the freest
academic position in the country and
maybe on earth Wow
I mean really more freedom than a
tenured professor at Harvard has and
that was let's be honest it was both a
blessing and a curse if you decided to
use that freedom for good if you decided
to figure out how to innovate structures
that didn't exist anywhere else you
could do it and nobody could tell you
not to on the other hand if you decided
to you know take the rest of your career
off and you know teach with one hand
while you you know dealt with your
hobbies you could also get away with
murder and so that happened as well and
you know there was attention every every
good professor at Evergreen grumbles
about the fact that there are a large
number of people who are holding
positions there that they don't really
value and you know that the phrase that
we've that we typically used in private
on the faculty was that evergreen paid
in freedom which meant that it didn't
pay well wasn't a good paying job but
the ability to have a blank canvas and
decide how you were you know what you
want to teach and in what way and to
innovate new mechanisms and take
students off campus for a week or two or
ten that freedom was a very valuable
commodity that Evergreen undervalued the
whole time it should have it should have
leveled with people that it was hiring
and it should have said look this job is
not going to make you wealthy but it can
make you very happy if you have the
temperament that really wants to figure
out what's possible so as this was
unfolding and now you went public and
you also did rogen and you were on
Tucker Carlson where you said I'm deeply
progressive because suddenly you were
sort of getting crap from you know your
side so to speak and you were getting
embraced by perhaps a different side and
I do want to get a little more into that
now because it shows what a sort of
crazy realignment politically we've had
these days were you shocked how deep it
went so you went public
you were you were giving the facts you
were exposing sort of the corruption and
how it went all the way up to the
administration and all that I think from
that first interview we did I think you
thought that there would be a course
correction in your
there was a chance for a course
correction and at least the way I read
the last year at no point was there even
a slowdown or any reflection from the
administration and the rest of it they
they just went in on this I am
completely shocked yeah by the fact that
the world's recognition of just how off
things were at Evergreen did not force
an acknowledgment that something was
wrong so I would not have been surprised
if Evergreen had backed off cynically if
they had privately said actually we were
on the right track
we were Mis portrayed and but we
nonetheless have to acknowledge what the
world is saying to us the fact that that
did not happen at all still shocks me
and I can't explain it
because you have a president who is
widely understood to be is there a
polite word for bonkers bananas - but
bonkers you know wackadoodle - yeah yeah
but in any case we have a president who
was I mean look he's the Mad King right
he's the Mad King and you've got a whole
bunch of people standing around
accepting his authority when in fact
he's an outsider his understanding of
the college or his plans for the college
are completely inconsistent with the
values that the college was founded on
yeah and were they really accepting his
authority because there are moments in
in the chaos of this that these videos
are posted where he can't even leave to
go to the bathroom and it's like he was
also a hostage in this in his own maybe
his own like perverted dream or
something you know I mean he was both
puppet and puppeteer yeah okay and so
the thing is yes he is held hostage in
those things but I believe he's a
willing hostage in the sense that he's
trying to accomplish something and you
know look it tells the whole tale once
you say what we are doing is about
equity there is a whole swath of people
that cannot figure out how they would
object no matter what it is then you say
next no matter what your plan is
if you've said that it is for the
purpose
of racial equity then a whole section of
the population will just fall in
lockstep what is that what is that
psychologically do you think oh I know
because I think we're seeing this
everywhere now this is not just
something that's happening at
universities anymore this is happening
all over society I wish I could say that
it is an error in cognition that people
are seeing it incorrectly what I know
for sure now as well as anybody on earth
is that the part of people's minds that
drives them in the direction of silence
of self-editing of all of these things
is actually accurately perceiving a
threat that it cannot manage now I'm not
looking for sympathy I do not have my
job anymore and I miss it it was a great
job however I've landed on my feet I'm I
wouldn't trade my position for any other
I like where I am however first of all
there's not an infinite number of those
positions in the world mhm so most
people who are looking at some sort of
an equity and inclusion juggernaut who
are thinking should I stand up actually
have to ask themselves what happens if I
do do I have an economic plan B for my
family right anybody who doesn't have an
economic plan B for their family and I
have to say as much as I would like
Evergreen to be a place in which all the
faculty had enough skills that they
could go do something else if they have
to they don't write they can't easily
move to another college because the way
they teach at Evergreen doesn't create a
CV that will get you hired elsewhere
easily and so I think lots of people are
looking ahead and saying if I stand up
and I say the right thing now what what
what will become of me and the problem
the place where I you know I have
sympathy for anybody who sees that and
says I don't have a plan B I don't know
what to do where I lose sympathy with
them is when they then having made that
calculation rationalize what they are
saying and then they join not
reluctantly but they become enthusiastic
allies of this movement in order to
basically they sell the rest of us out
right and in a weird way they almost
have to do that psychologically to live
with themselves right I mean otherwise
you realize that I mean then you are a
sellout in the you know it it's harsh
but it's true but what I'm so fat why
the reason I'm so fascinated with this
is because as you know I've been on tour
with Peterson for the last couple months
and I think this is the number one
question that we get asked people want
to speak up and they are afraid of
losing their jobs and and I think that's
why your story resonated with so many
people because people were looking at
you and going well it's pretty freakin
obvious this guy's not a racist he's not
a hater
he's a self-identified lefty and
progressive and all of these things and
somehow he stood up to the monster and I
think the fact that you're still here
and you're acting you're not employed at
the moment and I do want to discuss that
a little bit too but the fact that
you're still here you're alive you're
still willing to talk about these things
I think that's the type of courage that
people are looking for at the moment
well you know I do so I have to say for
I don't know a year now I have had these
interactions you know a couple times a
day somebody will come up to me on the
street and unless I'm in Olympia it's
always nice right people have people say
even sans beard they're still coming up
to actually that has reduced if I think
I'm not quite sure yeah there is that
who I think it is or is that Eric or
super I don't know but you go buzz cut
and then you're scot-free Ben oh man IV
yeah I could go on the lam they'd never
find me yeah but the thing is the it
raises questions the stuff that people
say to me about what they see on the
outside you know I get to compare that
to what the experience was on the inside
and so I've done a lot of thinking about
what it is is you know is there some
reason that that I stood up when others
didn't and I think you know it comes
down to something simple which you know
I'll just I'll just put it out there I
think people are rationalizing their
acceptance of this nonsense movement in
order to sleep
mm-hmm and for some reason that
particular switch works the opposite way
from you if I heard myself rationalizing
that I would not be able to sleep so in
order to sleep I had to stand up and you
know I'm lucky I have really good
friends I have a wonderful brother who
was you know friends with you and that
put us in contact and I have something
else to talk about you know evolutionary
biology is fascinating to people they
don't know how to think about it and
they're you know just as my students
were they're very interested to hear
what I have to say on the subject so
that means somehow even though I
couldn't see it exactly on May 23rd of
2017 there was a path forward for me
which you know it could come crashing
down tomorrow but so far it looks good
and I I regret nothing
is there an evolutionary explanation to
that type of person that either can
sleep or cannot sleep because you know
people come up to all of us all the time
now and they say I wish I could speak up
I don't want to lose my job my wife's
pissed at me I mean all of these things
and they're literally sometimes I'm
talking to people one on one and they're
whispering I mean this this this layer
of fear is seriously real and it is
sitting on top of people so is there an
evolutionary explanation why at the
moment it seems that a very small amount
of people are doing it absolutely and
for me just quickly I would just say for
me it's like I don't know if it's about
sleeping I just I just feel like I'm
doing what's right that's it it's
actually not more you know it's not more
confusing or needs more of an
explanation than that that's just what
I'm doing yeah there are two things to
say on this front one so I know we're
going to talk more about evolutionary
theory later on but yeah there is a way
in which evolutionary theory stalled
thirty years ago and I don't believe
that the explanation that you're looking
for is on the table in the way that you
know any evolutionist
you ask but say oh yeah the explanation
is over here but I do believe we can see
what it is there are a lot of
adaptations that do not map well onto
the individual if you look at the
individual and you say well why would
the person behave this way it seems
paradoxical sometimes if you look at
something larger than the individual and
it's not the group this is the thing
we've been caught in this argument about
group selection since the 60s and or
actually even earlier but that's where
it began to come to a head if you look
at the lineage that is to say population
of people who are related now talking
about ancestral ancestral populations
there are many characteristics that have
value for the lineage moving forward
that are hard to understand from the
point of view of the individuals and
many of the things that we have a really
hard time explaining including things
like homosexuality and religion many of
these things are adaptations that exist
at that slightly higher level and so
what I would say is an individual who
can't sleep if they're not doing the
right thing or if they hear themselves
rationalizing that individual is not
well-suited to certain jobs but they're
very well suited to other jobs and the
idea that a population has an emergent
nature and that you know a division of
labor between you know I'm not telling
you that not rationalising is the way we
should all be they may well be that we
need certain people who are very good at
carefully rationalizing certain things
in order to get jobs done I mean I would
imagine if you are in the military if
you are in a position of command in the
military that there are certain things
that you have to rationalize in order to
win the war now I'm not saying I don't
like war I'm not saying that you know
every war should be one you know you
said you could mentor into a war that
isn't justified but once you've entered
into it that the goal is justified maybe
you have to rationalize
certain things you know you move troops
over here in order to protect something
over there well what are you doing to
these people you may be sending them to
their deaths so you know even talking
about it makes it makes me uncomfortable
because it's not something I would be
good at but the point is when you look
at the population and the fact is the
populations that we have alive on earth
today are all winners right these are
the winners irrespective of how you got
here
irrespective of how oppressed your
population looks in relation to others
somehow you made it to the present
you're a winner those winning
populations had many characteristics
within them and they knew how to call
upon these people and you know sideline
those people and then switch it up at
the point you arrive somewhere else
where different skills are necessary so
in essence yeah I think there's a very
simple evolutionary explanation and some
of us have certain skills other people
have other skills and the real trick is
can you figure out the switching
mechanism that decides what to call on
at what moment that seems to be the key
part of this right I mean that's it it's
like some people are gonna do it some
people some people know they should do
it and won't do it some people probably
shouldn't do it and do do it and and
everything in between well you know I
you probably have this experience too
but when I when people come up to me and
they talk to me there's there's a couple
different styles of conversation that
unfold you know there's lots of people
who want to you know apologize for what
happened to me which I always find odd
you know unless they were there in the
room right unless it was them but I'm
guessing those people have not ever
contact me but you know some people want
to apologize some people you know want
to thank me and some people there's this
one thread which is I'm facing something
like this - yeah can you give me some
advice and you know I always say the
same sort of thing to them and it throws
them you know I always say look it's not
safe
you have to think very carefully about
what you're doing and don't kid yourself
about what you're signing up for and you
know you can look you just watch in
their eyes as they
grapple with the fact that they didn't
get what they wanted for me what they
wanted to be told they wanted somebody
to egg them on and then say do it it's
the right thing it'll work out and you
tell them oh it may not work out and you
know there's a moment of heartbreak but
my hope is that the people who should do
it have to go through that little
heartbreak in order to get to the other
side and so I among my various jobs at
the moment is to show people the abyss
now to say look is this the abyss you
want to jump if it is nobody can tell
you that but you I certainly can't yeah
I'd be irresponsible of me to tell
people to do something like what I did
because you could get you could get
maimed yeah and in a way it's it's sort
of the shows that I'm most proud of here
are the ones where I was able to
facilitate a little bit of that so it's
sitting down with you it's sitting down
with Lindsey Shepherd who went through
something very similar it's sitting down
with James d'amour these people who did
not ask to be heroes who even if I say
the word hero I can see you're
uncomfortable you know you mean like the
people that didn't want this but somehow
it got thrust upon them and then and
then they got there and then hopefully I
was able to amplify that a little bit
which then spreads that out to all sorts
of other people which is pretty cool so
let's let's I know I don't want to do
this for obviously the entire interview
so let's just say one thing yeah one of
us yeah what we'll do a bit more so
there's one thing that is and I believe
there's a little caveat to it if you do
it and you do it for the right reasons
in other words you could do it cynically
you could stand up against one of these
things in order to see if you couldn't
get famous or something people will see
through that right especially the people
who've gone ahead down this road because
they know something about it but if you
do it for the right reasons if you're
really trying to advance the ball to
challenge a bad narrative the people who
have gone through this recognize mm-hmm
and you know it won't feed you but it is
very reassuring to discover other people
who
see the corrupt narrative who understand
what happens when you challenge it so
anyway if if you're hungry to meet other
people like that standing up you know
you got to figure out what you're gonna
do to feed yourself but it does put you
in contact with lots of people who are
very worthwhile
yeah it's so interesting because again
after being with Peterson it's like
people will say to him you know I want
to get a new job should I just quit my
job tomorrow it's like you have to
seriously think about what your options
are you may hate your job it doesn't
mean you can leave tomorrow right you
got to think about all of this seriously
and I think that that is the key here so
I'm curious how much of this has shifted
what you think politically because you
do talk about politics now and I know
when I had you in there for the first
time I think I said to you we'll revisit
this question because I thought here's a
guy that's that I come from a very
similar political place as him as a
progressive and all of these things and
now I see you know as you know I
consider myself a classical liberal and
I and I love libertarian ideas obviously
we just did stand-up together last night
in Brea California you and your brother
joined me on stage for the for the
second half and it was mostly a
conservative crowd there were some Trump
people there were some lefties and some
liberals but you know mostly
conservatives and they they love you
guys
and yet you both still identify as
lefties and the whole thing and I wonder
now a year and a half later are you
shocked at that that you are now really
liked by people that perhaps you thought
were your ideological opponents and now
you're sort of on the outs with the
people that you used to be allies with
okay that's that's a good question I get
one every episode I am heartened and
flabbergasted by what I encounter on the
centre-right you know this is not the
Republican Party that I remember from my
youth this is a very different entity
and I think it has a lot of refugees
who've been driven out of other places
and they've grouped their because I
don't know because
because something over there is making
sense tonight well as you said to me the
first time we met debut have PTSD
protocol from the veterans and I must
say we should we should return to this
but I was very heartened to hear you
bring that up during your episode with
with Ben Shapiro and Eric and and Jordan
you you went through a cool exercise
which I think deserves a place with
steel Manning and your exercise I think
was something like where is someplace
that you suspect your own thinking might
be incorrect and you brought up
political PTSD as a place to pay
attention to but let's just say I am
shocked that the centre-right seems to
be you know it has protective custody of
liberty and very speech and science of
all things I mean how the heck did the
centre-right end to end up having
custody of these things which are
traditionally things that the right is
uneasy about and the left has has
defended but nonetheless the people who
value them are where they are I think
they do have something wrong you your
initial question was has this changed my
political view and I think one of the
everybody said it would and you know I I
believe I'm being honest with myself
when I say really hasn't changed my view
of what is true politically much if at
all I think because what I believe is
true isn't predicated on anything social
nothing right in other words these are
conclusions that I reached through game
theory and evolutionary thinking and
observation of the political landscape
they're not things you know it wasn't
that I went to a dinner party and had a
good time and fell in with their
political idea right so it's not you
know the fact that I am not welcomed in
certain quadrants of the left doesn't
change anything about what's true at all
right it can't so I understand that but
at the same time I mean you can go to
I've done public events with you that
are usually we're usually invited by
libertarian organizations
we've done some lying ran things
together and a couple other things
and I think everything that we've done
publicly and when you've joined me for
stand-up the crowds
all basically seem to be on the right as
you're saying this sort of new this new
center-right that maybe needs a better
phrase than that cuz center right sort
it need something sexier than that per
se but I mean have you been invited
anywhere by progressives to tell your
story or to get some camaraderie or
empathy or sympathy or kudos or anything
other than guff very occasionally and
only slightly I mean the the asymmetry
is amazing and I must say one of the
most interesting things to me about the
early phase of you know this public part
of my life is that initially there was
just this overwhelming message that came
back at me you are a conservative or
well but it's a cousin or something that
and welcome to the dark side I think is
what they usually do say that yeah and
then at the point that the phrase IDW
showed up on the landscape then there
was this point about oh the IDW is a you
know right-wing movement or something
like that and so there's a trajectory
there's there's something we track
immediate effects pretty well as people
we can observe them and detect them
there's often a slower pattern that is
harder for us to see and so just by
analogy I find this is true with healing
you know just physical healing if you do
damage to your knee for example there's
a one-month healing trajectory but
there's also a one-year and a five-year
trajectory and they're much harder to
spot mm-hmm so anyway the the
interesting thing is the challenge of
your on the right or now surely you will
be moving to the right you know that was
just an overwhelming message that came
back but the ability to talk back to
that message and say actually no still
on the left actually part of a left you
don't even remember exists and one of my
fears is that all of the stuff that the
left was correct about is not getting
properly credited now so to the extent
if people have seen this hidden tribes
report that came out maybe a month ago
now that says that there's this vast el
zosky ayah 80 percent in the middle who
do agree on
you know the desirability of a fair
society that doesn't burden one
population in order to enrich another
and you know that we basically share
that basically it's only eight percent
actually that buy into this hyper
political correctness and there and the
rest right it's a tiny fringe on the
authoritarian left and it's a tiny
fringe on the you know the white
nationalist right and the rest of us in
the middle know we're not in perfect
agreement we don't agree on the order of
the priorities but we do agree basically
on what a good society would function
like and that a lot of the gains I mean
you know the ability to be gay and out
and function in society without that
being a tremendous obstacle that that's
something that you know the left
deserves credit for racial equality
you know equity is a different beast by
virtue of the new I hesitate to even
call it a definition because it's not a
definition in the standard sense but
equality these are traditional left
values and we were right about mmm-hmm
and so the fact that these things are
now no longer controversial that belongs
in the discussion to the left has been
right about some stuff it's also been
wrong about some stuff and the right has
been right about some stuff and it's
been wrong about some stuff and it is
time for that conversation absolutely
and that's why I don't denigrate what it
was I am upset with what it is and
perhaps guys like you and your brother
and Sam some people that still identify
as left these will be able to do a
reclamation project that I just don't
see anymore I see sort of more that this
thing needs to burn so out of the ashes
of Phoenix can rise that's just maybe a
little bit of a tactical thing but let's
just jump back to an evolutionary
explanation for some of this so I asked
you about why some people can do this
from an evolutionary perspective why
some people are able to step up and some
people aren't what about what's the
evolutionary explanation for why this
let's say 8% very loud but small
people feel the need to purge everyone
is there is there an evolutionary
because that seems it would be almost
counter to evolution you'd want to have
more commonalities with people and bring
in a big tent but what I see them
consistently doing is just getting rid
of everybody who dare you know talk back
to the to the God well you know I I wish
I had known this was gonna come up
because I would have looked it up but
there was a put me on the spot there was
a a report that emerged maybe it was six
or eight months ago that I don't you
know I haven't looked into it and it's
not my area of specialty but it sounded
right to me and what it said was that
there is a particular there's a
particular personality trait
authoritarianism that isn't ideological
it doesn't really care whether it's you
know defending fascism or communism
mm-hmm what it wants to do is boss
people around and that essentially
what's confusing to people is that at
the moment these dyed-in-the-wool
authoritarians are concentrated over on
the left and they're saying stuff that
sounds nominally like leftist stuff but
that you know we're the winds to shift
and the authoritarians of the moment to
be over on the right they'd be there and
so that that makes sense to me and what
I would like people yourself included to
consider is that there is almost no
point in engaging those people mm-hmm
right this question of the importance of
Liberty is settled right the 80 percent
of us in the middle all get the fringe
on the far left and the far right are I
don't want to say safe to ignore because
they can always rise up and become
important as the one on the left is
doing however that's not where the game
is the game is all of the people who
can't figure out how to escape from the
stigma and all that is driving
civilization so all of the people who
are falling in line with
going on on the authoritarian left those
are the people to reach mm-hmm and what
you raised about you know let's say the
audience last night at the comedy club
and you know this is reliable this was
the second one I did with you is exactly
the same the first time the thing that
is so heartening is you know I can come
into a room and you're right that room
last night must have been 95 percent
right of center yeah and first thing you
tell them is here's a progressive I'm I
tell them I'm a radical right yeah it
doesn't dampen their enthusiasm one bit
in fact it they're thrilled to discover
that things are not so bleak and that
there is somebody on the other side of
this thing who's still talking
reasonably and can hear them and can see
them and doesn't think that they're
racist and out of control and so anyway
you know I know I take a lot of flack
for you know interacting with the right
and I'm not listening to that flag yeah
good it is the best thing we can do is
to engage and you know when you spot the
humanity of the people on the other side
then to the extent that we differ over
something we can talk about it all right
well we could keep going down this
Pandora's box of lunacy related to
everything that you've been through but
let's do let's just catch it up to where
we are now and we can start looking at
the future a little bit so you and your
wife Heather who you reference Heather
hang who's been on the show who's a
brilliant professor as well and and and
has that that brave evolutionary tick
that you have to had end up marrying a
woman that was gonna have the same
evolutionary tick as you that's pretty
good you really want to know the answer
yeah Heather and I we were not going out
but we were friends in high school and
you know there's I don't know that how
the others will understand the the
phrase but the one that runs in my head
is somebody goes to high school with the
girl you should marry and it might be
you right so anyway in my case you know
I don't know how because you know I was
I was a confused kid like every other
kid that age there was something about
her that
so very right and I have to say I was
right about that best decision I ever
made was she ever pissed at you during
this because you sort of thrust her in
the spotlight too and the fact is both
of you left your jobs you got a five
hundred thousand dollar settlement for
two tenured positions which to some
people that's out five hundred thousand
dollars sounds like it sounds like a lot
of money but but you this is your life's
work you and your wife you've since
relocated your family and your two kids
so this is this is massive five hundred
grand and the scheme of that is not a
lot but was she ever bothered or
hesitant by what you were doing cuz she
didn't go public about this until a bit
after she was never pissed not for a
minute
she and I were in complete agreement we
saw the same thing unfold at Evergreen
the the nature of our teaching at
Evergreen was kind of interesting in the
sense that we had like a little
undeclared graduate program in
evolutionary biology where we couldn't
award you a master's degree but if you
were interested in evolutionary biology
and many people didn't know they were
but they would take my program and then
I would sort of nudge them over towards
Heather's program so we had students
bouncing back and forth and we had a
community of people that were in our
circle so the basic point is that
creates a an opportunity for every night
at dinner Heather and I would compare
notes what we were seeing at the college
and all these things talk about you know
students you know what the students
blind spot is what they do particularly
well and as this unfolded Heather and I
saw the identical picture and or maybe
the way to say it is the the picture of
what was happening emerged between us as
we discussed it and she was let's put it
this way what put me in the bull's eye
was the emails that I wrote and the
thing as I said in faculty meetings I
never wrote an email that Heather didn't
look at first and tell me
it's ready and frankly there were a lot
of emails that I didn't send and if I
made one error I believe I should have
sent everyone right because what they do
is they leave a historical record of
what is taking place so the dissent was
in retrospect very clear as he went back
to the mails but anyway yeah Heather
Heather was in complete agreement the
whole time and I think the confrontation
was less in keeping with you know her
personality traits than mine but in
terms of her commitment and her belief
in what we were doing it was a team
effort there's a lesson in marriage
right there there's probably many
lessons in marriage oh very yeah all
right so let's just get to where you are
now you guys have left Washington
neither one of you are teaching at the
moment you're trying to figure out what
your future is I assume the same with
Heather what is that like number one and
number two I think a lot of people would
be surprised to know that schools have
not thrown offers at you I mean you you
have a seriously great public profile
now you are respected by so many people
you have you have fans and not just
students now you have former students
but you have fans that would love to
sign up for courses that you would be
teaching and all sorts of things or I
think most people would look at this on
their face and think wow what an asset
this would get this guy would be not
only intellectually but PR wise and all
that that's not where we're at it's
absolutely not and it it does say
something and yeah I'm I'm an outsider
to whatever discussions it is that
result in nothing of that sort coming
our way but it is conspicuous so you
asked what it's what it's like you know
I'm having a very unusual experience in
life and you know my my life was great
before any of this happened it's great
now the lack of security is frightening
when I stare at it you know
Heather and I have two kids and if we
didn't we would be in a different
position we could take risks and we
could afford to go through you know
years of austerity but as it is we have
responsibilities and you know our kids
didn't sign up for this mm-hmm so I mean
they would have are you saying they
didn't get that gene what are you
telling me oh no they're poor but yeah
it's our responsibility to protect them
and say you know the whole thing has
been frightening from the point of view
of what it means for the future because
literally I don't know it seems like
things are headed along a path in which
you know the settlement that you
mentioned is a tiny fraction of what we
would have earned over the rest of our
careers incurring a huge amount of it
was burned up paying lawyers and taxes
you know you get all that money in one
chunk so we got about two years of
buffer money from that but it wasn't
wasn't like we got bought out we we
could have in a state that had punitive
damages we likely could have won
something much more like four million
bucks for the amount of income that we
would have earned over the rest of our
careers and why did you guys not go that
route because I think a lot of people
when they saw the number I remember when
I saw the number I just saw an article
or something and I was like woah woah
woah why so low because Washington is
one of eleven states without punitive
damages it's that simple
Oh woah I thought you said that
Washington did have punitive damages oh
oh oh I just misheard you okay so that
that that caused us to effectively cut
our losses and decide that it there was
nothing to be done we did the best we
could with evergreen and cutting our
ties with them at the point that they
made it clear I mean they they behaved
atrociously in negotiations for one
thing they dragged their heels they
wouldn't sit down with us until we were
already back on contract for the next
year
fully assuming that we would be going
back into a classroom but what would it
be like to walk onto a campus that is
you know paying a PR firm to demonize
you right what would that be like and we
would have
but they they insulted us in
negotiations they offered us panic
buttons right as if I spoke panic
buttons in the room literally yeah like
as if the problem was that we were panic
yeah
rather than that they had you know they
could have at least I offered you a
counter baseball bat
wouldn't that have been nice right some
but they didn't and you know hobbling
the police the whole thing was a fiasco
so we cut our losses we we moved we
moved to Portland which is wonderful I
know that's in some ways not its
reputation but it is a marvelous place
you went to the only more progressive
place it does seem that we have well
you're a glutton for punishment on to
the belly of the beast but I you know
the beauty of Portland you know there's
a beauty and there's a tragedy there is
this equity and inclusion thing and it
seems to go up to the mayor's office who
happens to also frightening Lee in a
parallel to evergreen be the police
commissioner so he can stand down the
police and and has done so in some
circumstance well that video from a
couple weeks ago with an tyfa basically
running traffic in the middle of
portland i mean it's it's unfathomable
that that's happening in the streets of
a united state city right right it is
they are flirting with the same i mean
it is the same story as evergreen except
this is a major American city you know
to have a college play games with
literal Anarchy is dangerous enough to
have a city doing it I shudder to think
you didn't want to think about Texas I
really on this tour I got to tell you
San Antonio I think you'd have a field
day over there well but here's the thing
the other part of liberalism is also
true in Portland so I never encounter
the antifoam madness and the mayor and
his confusion you know it's like the
mayor of your town you never never run
into it what I do run into is a clean
functional city people as far as I can
tell are very decent to each other
you know they make provisions for
cyclists to commute around the place so
I think in some sense Portland is it
shows exactly the conflict between the
left's better instincts and its worst
instincts and I hope that it will come
around to the kind of enlightened
progressivism that used to exist rather
than the naive progressivism that seems
to have taken over
[Music]